in 2001 I was a brand-new shiny doctor
planning to save the world my first job
was working for three months on a lung
cancer unit nearly all of my patients
were smokers or ex smokers and most of
them had started smoking when they were
children or in their early teens and
despite living in a beautiful wealthy
country with access to the most
sophisticated medicines nearly every
single one of my patients died
everyone knows tobacco is bad but when
you see the impact firsthand day by day
it leaves a very deep impression ten
years later I'm a radiation oncologist
fully aware of the suffering caused by
tobacco I'm sitting at the hospital
cafeteria having my first-ever meeting
with a representative from my
superannuation fund it was thrilling I'm
sure you can imagine he tells me I'm in
the default option and I said our option
does that mean there are other options
he looked at me rolled his eyes and said
well there is this one green e option
for people who have a problem with
investing in mining alcohol or tobacco I
said did you decide about he said yes I
said so are you telling me I'm currently
investing in tobacco and he said oh yes
everyone is when you invest in a company
you own part of that company you want
that company to grow and succeed and
thrive you want that company to attract
new customers you want that company to
sell more of its products and when it
comes to tobacco I couldn't think of
anything that I wanted less now I know
you can only see one person standing
here on this big red dot on this
enormous stage but instead I would like
you to imagine that you're looking at 7
million people crammed up here beside me
today 7 million people across the world
have died as a result of tobacco in the
past year alone just imagine if a brand
new industry were launched today and by
the end of next June that industry's
products had killed 7 million people
would any of us invest in that new
deadly industry tobacco is one of the
most pressing global issues of our time
and most of us are far more complicit in
the problem than we may realize so the
Superfund representative explained to me
that tobacco companies would be found in
the international shares portion of my
portfolio so I asked him well which
international shares do I have he got
back to me two weeks later with this
list my number 1 holding in
international shares was British
American Tobacco number 2 Imperial
Tobacco number 4 Philip Morris and
number 5 the Swedish Match company four
of the top five companies which iveco
companies my investments and oncologist
and then I realized it wasn't just me
it was all members of my super fund and
then I realized it wasn't just my super
fund it was all of them and then I
realized it wasn't just superannuation
funds
it was banks insurers and fund managers
and then I realized it wasn't just
Australia it was the entire global
finance sector completely tangled up
with the tobacco industry
the industry that makes products that
kill seven million people every year
so I started discussing the issue with
my superannuation fund and I've been
discussing it ever since finance leaders
have many challenging issues to deal
with these days so I suggest they adopt
a framework that clearly articulates why
it is reasonable to take a strong
position on tobacco
I suggest finance leaders ask a suite of
three questions of any company in which
they might invest our money question one
can the product made by the company be
used safely no is the answer for tobacco
companies the
is the only safe number of cigarettes
for a human being it could not be more
black and what question - is the problem
caused by the company so significant on
a global level that it is subject to a
UN treaty or convention yes is the
answer for tobacco indeed there is a UN
tobacco treaty that has been ratified by
180 countries the treaty was created
because of the catastrophic global
impact of tobacco the current forecast
is that the world is on track for 1
billion tobacco related deaths this
century 1 billion deaths there's only 7
billion of us questions 3 relates to the
concept of engagement many financial
organizations genuinely want to be good
corporate citizens they want to use
their shareholder power to sit down with
companies engage with them and encourage
them to do better things so the question
is can engagement with the company be an
effective lever for change no is the
answer for tobacco companies engagement
with the tobacco industry is futile the
only acceptable outcome would be if
tobacco companies ceased their primary
business in fact engagement with the
tobacco industry has never led to less
human death when we consider that
framework three simple questions we can
see that it is reasonable and defensible
to take a strong position and exclude
investment in the tobacco industry in
addition to the UN tobacco treaty there
is in fact another global treaty that
demands that we act on tobacco in 2015
the UN adopted the sustainable
development goals
now we're talking about tobacco and I
know you're going to jump straight to
number three good health and well-being
and indeed ramping up tobacco control
regulation is essential if we are going
to achieve that goal however look a bit
more deeply and you will find that 13 of
the 17 goals cannot be achieved unless
there is a major shake-up of
the tobacco industry personally my
favorite goal is number 17 partnerships
for the goals at present we have the
entire global health sector doing
everything it can to help the tidal wave
of patient suffering as a result of
tobacco but that said in the past year
alone seven million people have died so
clearly that is not enough we also have
government's aligned on tobacco 180 of
them busily trying to implement the
provisions of the UN tobacco treaty but
that too is not enough if the global
finance sector continues to lend money
to tobacco companies to invest in
tobacco companies and to strive to
profit from tobacco companies we are
working against each other now if we are
going to disrupt what doctors call the
global tobacco epidemic we need every
sector of society to stand side-by-side
and be part of the solution so I call on
finance leaders to implement a framework
to deal with sensitive issues and I call
on them to uphold global conventions but
in addition there are business risks
pure financial risks associated with
being invested in the tobacco industry
over the long term and I ask finance
leaders to consider them the first risk
is that fewer and fewer people will
smoke as a result of increasing tobacco
regulation when these warnings were put
on cigarette packets in Canada the first
response of smokers was to give them
right back to the salespeople and say
could you please just give me the ones
that say they'll kill me
regulation gets noticed regulation
reduces consumption and we have 180
countries committed to more regulation
let's talk about litigation and the risk
that presents at present it's the
business model of the tobacco industry
that is being challenged currently the
tobacco industry externalizes all of the
health costs associated with tobacco
governments pay communities pay you pay
I pay the tobacco industry externalizes
all those costs with an estimated 1
trillion US dollars per year yet they
internalize and privatize the profits in
2015 in Quebec province the courts
determined that the tobacco industry was
indeed responsible for those health
costs and ordered them to pay 15 billion
u.s. dollars that case is under appeal
but it begs the question why should any
of us in any country be paying for the
costs of the tobacco industry let's move
on to supply chain and the risk there it
is not well known but the tobacco
industry significantly relies on child
labor in March this year the
International Labor Organization issued
a report which stated in tobacco growing
communities child labor is rampant the
US Department of Labor currently lists
16 countries that use children to
produce tobacco leaf scrutiny of supply
chains is intensifying and that cannot
continue to escape public attention
finally there is also reputation risk to
consider for individuals and
organizations that continue to maintain
an affiliation with the tobacco industry
in countless surveys the tobacco
industry ranks as the world's least
reputable industry let's just look at
the impact on children globally every
single day it is estimated that 100
thousand children start smoking that's
enough
children to fit inside the Melbourne
Cricket Ground and most of those
children are from the poorest
communities on earth here in Australia
the average age that people start
smoking is 16 years and 2 months they
look pretty young to me but the worst
thing here is that while we don't have
data from every country on earth we
believe that is the oldest age
everywhere else is younger now for the
good news
things are changing the finance sector
is coming to the party after around 2000
meetings with finance leaders primarily
in the cafe's of Melbourne and Sydney
and London and Paris in New York and all
across the globe momentum moving away
from investment in the tobacco industry
is starting to snowball finance leaders
are alarmed when they're presented with
the facts and overwhelmingly
they want to be part of the solution
here in Australia we now have ten
million six hundred and thirty six
thousand one hundred and one
superannuation accounts that are tobacco
free that one is Martin by the way
there is still a lot of work to be done
but I've watched the conversation go
from should we go to backhoe free - why
haven't we done it yet in the past year
alone major tobacco free moves have been
made by leading financial organizations
in eight different countries in
Australia New Zealand the Netherlands
Sweden Denmark France Ireland and the
USA by sovereign wealth funds fund
managers pension funds banks insurers
and reinsurers since tobacco free
portfolios began more than six billion
dollars has been redirected away from
investment in the tobacco industry the
case study is well and truly proven when
making the tobacco free announcement in
March this year the CEO of a and P
capital said we are not prepared to
deliver investment returns at any cost
to society and that is a question we
need to ask ourselves is there no
baseline standard below which we will
not sink to make profit along the way
I've had a lot of help and incredible
support now if you are trying to do
something I highly recommend that you
have a princess on your team Her Royal
Highness Princess Dina murud is the
global ambassador for this work we also
have a lord a knight a former premier a
former federal minister and a stack of
CEOs but the capacity to change things
does not rest exclusively with these
highly influential people the power to
do that is with all of us everyone here
can be part of the solution in fact
everyone here must be part of the
solution most people in this room owned
companies via their superannuation funds
their banks and their insurers and it is
time for us to ask them are they
investing our money in companies that
make products that kill seven million
people every year it's your money it's
my money it's our money and that is a
very reasonable question pretty cramped
up here with 7 million people beside me
today
but if we don't act now and act together
we'll need to make way for 1 billion
people before the end of this century
and this is a very big stage but there
is no more room thank you
[Applause]
[Music]